hello everybody and
welcome to today's webinar this is peter
cooper and
i'm going to turn it over to francoise
tibor nissan who's going to talk to you
about webrep take it away francois
all right thank you peter so and thank
you everyone for joining us
this morning this afternoon this evening
i don't know where you are
uh today i'm going to be talking about a
new
service that we have at ncbi called rat
and i will explain how you can use web
wrap to assemble and annotating
your prokaryotic genomes
so the outline of the talk is the
following first i will explain what rapt
is
and we'll explain what the main
components of the pipelines are
designed gap then i will give you a
little demo on how you can
wrap how you can use wrapped and
finally i will show you give you a
little bit of a glance of how you can
use run wrapped on your own machine if
you wish
so let's get started so wrapped stands
for the read assembly and
annotation pipeline tool it's a tool
that right this
that was designed to help microbiology
microbiologists
work with what we think is a typical
workflow where
you may be collecting some samples you
bring them back to the lab
you grow them you extract dna from them
you sequence the genome then you have to
assemble it
you annotate to figure out what the gene
content is
and then you move on to that to the
analysis part which could be
comparing gene contents between that
genome you choose sequence
to others um in a database or in a
collection that you have
or you may be looking at a particular
biosynthetic pathways and analyzing
what's missing in your genome on what's
present
or you may be building some phylogenetic
trees
and try to understand how your genome
differs from
others so the the piece that wrapped
is attempting to help you with is with
the assembly and the annotation part
with wrapped as i just said you can
assemble and annotate a genome for a
bacteria
or an archaea in just a few hours and
you can do it right out of the
sequencing machine
that means you can quickly characterize
your starting material determine whether
you have an issue with your isolation
procedure or whether you have a
contaminated colony
and you can get an annotation that is
consistent
with the annotation that you would find
on the website assemblies
thereby making any comparisons uh with
the refseq collection easier
and another tidbit is you can
use wrap to confirm the organism that
was assigned to the reeds and
potentially
again identify issues of contamination
or
samples that have been swapped or things
like that
so the components of rat are skisa skisa
is an assembler that was designed for
short reads it was designed by sasha
superoff and richard garwola here at
ncbi it's available as a standalone
tool that you can run on your own
machine it's on github
and it also contains a pgap
the annotation pipeline used for the
annotation of website genomes
and this pipeline is also available as a
standalone tool
and you can get the command line
interface
for this picapp tool on github as well
so as i just explained wrapped is really
the union of those two things together
and it is available as a standalone tool
on github
but what i'm going to talk about today
is how you can
run it directly from our website without
having to download
anything so a word about the two
the main components of uh of rat
the assembly is done with ski thumb
skeiza
assembles illumina reads in parallel
it's based on the brain graph
it's fast and repeatable which is an
important reason why we're using it
and it also has the advantage of
handling low levels of contamination
relatively well
i put here two figures that um
compares uh skeeza to other popular
assemblers uh that are based on the
assembly of 381
sra ones that were uh sequenced by fto
argos
and you can see the average counting n50
for skeeza
is uh is relatively good compared to
what you'd get with a space and negative
hit
um the average time it takes for skeeza
to run
is also pretty good on par uh
well a bit higher than mega hit and much
lower than spades
and then the right hand side is the
comparisons between
the sequence that was produced by skeeza
compared to uh
to high accuracy assemblies that were um
to a baseline of high accuracy assembly
that were generated uses those data
and you can see that we squeeze out the
number of mismatches that you get
compared to that gold standard
is um is the order of one
per 100 kb while for mega hit and spades
it tends to be more one two three four
or over four uh if you want more
information about giza i encourage you
to go to that genome biology paper that
is um
cited at the bottom of the slide the
other
important component of wrapped and
really what takes
the bulk of the computation in the rat
pipeline is the p-gap
the prokaryotic genome annotation
pipeline
as i said before this is the pipeline
that is used to
annotate rapid genomes so that's
currently about 220 000
um bacterial and archaeal genomes that
you can find in genbak
those were annotated with this piga
pipeline
it's an automated pipeline it um
predicts protein coding genes using a
combination of protein homology
ab initio calls using gene mark s2 plus
and it also gets help from
the protein profile hidden markov models
that are
both from outside sources such as pfem
and also from inside sources we curate
and we make and curate
hmms ourselves pgaap also predicts
non-coding genes
trnas using trna scan sc and
ribosomal rnas and small non-coding rnas
using
rfn and cm search after
the structural annotation of the genes
and there's an important functional
annotation step to p gap
and this functional annotation is done
uh
using a a lot of
expert curated hidden markov
hidden markov models blast rules
and cdd architectures with all of this
maintained on ncbi and at the last
resort
if we can't match an annotated protein
to an hmm or blast rule or ct
architecture
we will default to protein neurology to
name the protein
so again this is available as a
standalone tool on
on github all right so now let's move on
uh to
uh wrapped itself and specifically the
wrap service so the web service is
hosted at ncbi the address here is um
at the top of the slide uh so
this is a very quick workflow of how
that works
so you go to the home page you log in
and then you have the option of
supplying a genomic reads
into a different
either supply a run from the sequence
reader archive
so sra so that will be
an accession that starts with
s-r-r-e-r-r
or d-r-r or
if you're interested in assembling
genomic reads that are not in sra
something that you have just sequenced
provide
files of fasti or fastq file
uh they can be a fast day or fast queue
reads can be
pressed or not you will supply the
genomic reads
and you will submit so you receive the
the
job start notification and then you wait
a couple of hours
and after that you should receive an
email that lets you know the results are
ready to download
and um it gives you a link to a job
details page that reminds you
what the inputs for the job was and
that gives you a download button and you
download the results
and this is essentially it
a reminder this tool works on genomic
reads so this is not a tool
to assemble transcriptomic reads it
works on single isolates
so not on meta genomic data and it works
on illumina
or short high accuracy reads
all right so now uh let's uh
let's go on a tour of
uh rat let me show you
what it looks like hopefully you now see
my
my firefox my browser so here i am this
is a wrapped homepage
i'm already logged in here and i get a
little intro
and then i get the two options to input
the data if i wasn't logged in already
this is what you would see you would
have access to the home page you would
have to access to the documentation
and to the faqs but uh
on the home page you wouldn't have you
wouldn't be able to
upload anything you would have been able
to start any job you click
on login and here you're given the
option of
how you want to log in you can use um
google credentials if you're at nih nih
credential
and there's a lot of third-party signing
options that you can provide as well
from your institution
or others
so let's go back to uh
where to the to my page where i'm logged
in
so again i'm logged in it's visible here
on the top
um right so and let me show you
how you start a job so here i have
identified
a run of salmonella that i want to
assemble and then annotate
uh this run of salmonella is nsi
this is this is what it looks like in uh
in the sequence read archive
um you can see it's from an illumina my
seek
instrument it's smart genomics and
genomic
and it comes from a paired and library
which um uh not particularly relevant
for this
this part i'm going to copy
the um sra one
i paste it here and i click submit
so now um the process is verifying that
that sre accession is really for
a micro that it's really for a nokia or
bacteria and it also
verified that it was coming from a
genomic library and not transcriptomics
and not meta genomic okay so the
the job has been launched i can click on
there
and this is my job list
you can see at the top 5 19 12
14 my job has been launched
okay if i wanted to cancel it
i have this possibility here on the
right
i press cancel and i will be notified
very shortly
that my job was cancelled all right
let's go back to the home page and let
me show you how
you can upload
your own fasta fastu file
so um there are two possibilities
you may have a single file because you
have sequenced
a single end library
or you may have a single file because
you have sequence of paired
and library but the forward and the
reverse strand are interleaved in the
file
so in your file you have spot one
forward spot one reverse spot to forward
spot reverse etc the forward and the
reverse for
each spot are right next to each other
in the file
so that is one situation
if you have sequenced the paradigm
library you may
have two files one with the forward
reads
and one with the reverse feeds so you
need to select what situation is yours
so let me show you how to upload a
single file so again that file can be a
faster
it can be a fast queue it can be
g-zipped or it can be
uncompressed i'm going to chew the file
um i'm going to choose this one it's a
fast file from the e-coli genome
and i need to input a
is a charcoal like the input um
the string either you have it or you
don't have it it doesn't matter
i'm going to call it abc for this
example
and you submit and again
there's a step that it verifies the
organism
we want to make sure that the organism
that you provided is known to taxonomy
this is important because
what's in taxonomy is also the genetic
code
that is expected for this organism and
that genetic code
is important to know for the annotation
step
so that's the reason why it's important
that you put in
a species or a genus that is known to
taxonomy
so now the job has been launched i can
look again on my job list
and it's been queued so hopefully a
little bit
but soon ishakola abc and my input was e
coli dot fasta
all right so let's go back here and let
me show you
uh how you can upload two files
so essential so this is uh
this is a parent library with the
forward and the reverse read
um in different files
i've uploaded them and i said this is a
salmonella
genome but let's say i'm not sure what
the species is
i know that it's a samana i'm not quite
sure this
is okay you can input only the genus
genus is sufficient for us to determine
what the genetic code is
so you can input just your genome the
genus here no strain
no species we should be able to figure
it out
so again it's verifying that salmonella
is known to ncbi taxonomy
it's uploading the files and it should
shortly
start the jobs all right the job was
launched
let's go to the job list again and you
can see the job is skewed and the one i
launched just before
is now running all right so i
explained that you should receive email
notification when job starts so let me
go to my email
and you can see in the email i indeed
receive notification
so you should see the email here it
tells you job
xyz is started and tells you what's
what's going to happen
next and essentially what's going to
happen next is that you're going to get
some notification that your job
has finished so here i've got we're not
going to wait until
the jobs that we just launched are are
done
i'm going to show you um an example
of an email notification i received
yesterday
after one of the java launch was
finished
uh so this is what you get in the in the
in the description in the email it says
your job
xyz is finished and it explains how you
can download
the results so i'm going to click on the
job details page
uh uh that is in in the email
and this is what you get it's the
channel reminds you of
the job id the version of what you're
using
it reminds you what input you used and
what organism
was the input associated with and when
you created it
and very important you get a download
you click on the download
and then you have the option of saving
or opening
uh whichever whichever way you wish i go
to my uh
download folder and here it is
1220 this is the one i just uh
the results i just downloaded so note
that this is a targe easy
file so most people should have the 7zip
application to open and extract what's
in an
archive so this is
this is what the results are it's a
number of files so i'm going to go sort
of in order of when
when they're produced so
first thing that happens is wrap is uh
create an
assembly and so what you
the assembly itself in the is in the
file that is called skisa underscore at
um dot fa and let me view this
uh it should show up in a few minutes
this is a multifaceted file this should
look very familiar to you
and it contains all the sequences that
were assembled
there's also a little report that gives
you some information
about um what what exactly
uh was assembled and you can see that
particular
one um there was 54 sequences that
was assembled out of out of all the
reads in the
sr that was provided as input and
um it produced a 4.8 meg
genome which seems about appropriate for
salmonella
and the minimum sequence length was 340
the max maximum sequence length was uh
450 kb
um and the contig and 50 is 260 kv
and the l50 is 7. so basic information
about the assembly it's always good to
check that your assembly looks about
as you expect in terms of size and
in terms of uh amount of fragmentation
all right so now we've looked at the
assembly so let me show you
uh what you have in terms of uh the
annotation
so i'm going to show you first the
annot.gbk file which is the
genbak genbank format uh
so if you have ever looked in an entree
nucleotide
for a prokaryotic nucleotide genomic
sequence
uh this is typically what you would see
you have at the top
the name of the sequence uh below that
some information about where that
sequence comes from
um some links you can see here that it
provides the
sr from which we uh we assemble the
weeds
um provide the uh the organism
associated with the reeds
uh some um generic comment about how
the annotation was put together
and uh pretty pretty important here
it shows uh what type of feature were
annotated on the assembly
a very important point here is that even
though you're looking we're looking at
the record for
that particular content which is only
4kb
uh this block of text here is relevant
to the entire assembly
okay so what it's telling me here is
that
um this annotation was provided by pgap
and we suffered a revision from
january 11th and we annotated gene cds
rna trna
and cryon etc and we annotated
four thousand seven hundred and thirty
nine genes
among those four thousand six hundred
and thirty six that are coding
uh we also annotated some ribosomal rna
some complete some partial some trnas
it indicates the number of pseudogenes
that were
annotated and why they were thought to
be pseudogenes whether they were frame
shifted incomplete
or had some other issue and it also
indicates the number of crispr arrays
that were annotated
below that you get the annotation that
is
on this particular 4kb sequence that
is at at the top of the of the file
and so you get the genes their
coordinates
uh the coordinates of the cds on this um
on this 4kb sequence and uh
importantly it tells you hopefully what
the function of the protein
that is annotated is in this case
replication initiation
protein is provided as a name and you
get the translation
for the protein as well all that should
be very familiar
if you've ever looked at a a nucleotide
record for
a bacterial genomic record at the bottom
is
the actual sequence of uh of the
of the context and below that you get
the next contact
so this file dot gbk
lists all the contacts that are in the
assembly
with their annotation that's the bottom
line
all right so the annotation is also
provided
as a gff file if you want to load
the annotation to a viewer this is
probably the file that you would be
using
it is the same information as in the gbk
file but
it's in a table format that is aminable
to uh most browsers
um also worth mentioning uh the
dot fa file uh this one includes
all the the sequences all
um the proteins that were annotated on
the genome
um as as you can see here it's a
multi-faceted file
all right so moving on from
from annotation to another tidbit i
remember that i said that with wrap you
can confirm
the taxonomy of the organism
the organism name that was assigned to
the reeds at the beginning
so this is done using the average
nucleotide identity tool
which essentially compares the assembled
genome to all
the type material assemblies that are in
genbank
and it determines which of these start
genome assemblies
time specific assemblies is the closest
to the one that you provided
so let me show you what that looks like
so
this is the ni report in uh in text
format
so in this case the submitted organism
was the name that was associated with
the
sre accession it's on a species
species is not specified uh and has a
strain here
uh there's no um there's no type
there's actually no type a specimen for
that
organism because it's just a genus
essentially
there's no species associated with it
but nonetheless you can see below that
that organism name is confirmed
so eni agrees that salmonella
is the most likely identifier for
for the reads that were provided input
and
if you look below and so status is
confirmed with high confidence and if
you look below
the identity the percent identity match
to um
to type assemblies is best
with the lt2 reference genome for
salmonella enterica
and below that you've got other top
assemblies from antarctica
so very very strong suspicion that what
was provided
as a samurai species or undefined
species for salmonella is a salmonella
interactive genome so there are
situations where
you're going to find that the organism
you may find that the organism you enter
does not correspond to what a
i provided so this is a good reminder
that
you should go back in those cases and
reanalyze your sample make sure that
you've got
retracted correctly and potentially
rerun wrapped
using the corrected the eni provided
an organism to get
proper annotation
all right so this is about i have to
show you
about um the
output of rats so let me close this and
go back one more thing i want to show
you on the
uh the page for uh
wrapped okay so one thing when you're
the job list here
you have the option of sharing results
so for example
we could see a procurement genome that i
assembled a couple days ago
i've got the option to download which
will take you exactly to
what i showed you you can download them
the the
target output you can also share it so
you click on share
and you can either copy that link and
do whatever you wish
and it will open here it's
hooked to outlook so it opens an email
and in the text of the in the body of
the email you see a link to
uh to uh the results
so one thing about that so if you share
the results with a colleague or a friend
that friend that colleague which will
only have access to this particular
results
the user the the recipient of the email
will not have access to any other job
that you have run
and it will not be able to run any jobs
on your
behalf so strictly limited to that
particular set of uh
of results so
let me go back to the presentation a
couple of things to know about this
service
this is a pilot service so this is very
important that you provide your feedback
and your tasks in particular whether you
this is a service that is uh
that is useful to you how do you use the
results
and potentially what other tools would
you need that would make it even better
so really crucial for the future of the
project is
is your feedback uh one thing i did not
mention
but i'll do it now is that when you get
the
results of a run you also get
a link to the survey please answer the
survey after you looked at the results
and let us know what you think of the
results whether they're good they're bad
what you want to what you would want to
do with the tool any any feedback is
really appreciated
so through the feedback button or
through the survey
both uh whichever is easier for you
i also want to mention that this is not
a service that is
not designed to be high throughput each
user is limited to 30 jobs for a 30
day period so uh if you have
a need for a running thing
at scale this is not it however
you can use the standalone tool for that
and i will give that
a glimpse of that in a minute another
limitation is that of course
in order to run this the the your
your data you need to share the data
with ncbi in the sense that you need to
upload it
we do not do anything with the data you
upload
and we don't make it public we don't
look at what it is
so no concern there but if you're
working with very sensitive material or
you have
concerns about proprietary data
again this may be a concern so either
because you want to run at scale
or because um you have concerned about
sharing
uh i want to uh explain to you that
you can run wrap yourself on your own
machine
on the cloud in order to do this
i would encourage you to go to our
github site
and download the command line interface
that allows you
to um a a communicate
with a darker image that contains
wrapped
with uh using that command line uh
which just uh with just one command
you can start a job it's uh it's it's
very simple to
use also i want to stress that if you
are not um if you are a user of the
google cloud platform
there's a special implementation of wrap
for the cloud platform where you can
just launch from the google console
so you don't even need to secure a
virtual machine
in advance you just um launch the
process from the console and it will
take care of reserving the vm
and then shutting it down once you're
done and i'm not going to say much more
than that because we had a
webinar earlier in the in the year that
is
available on the ndlm youtube channel
and that is here
finally i want to acknowledge all the
people who have made that work possible
that includes everyone that worked on
packaging
pgap and then on packages wrapped into a
docker image
everyone that worked on the interface
for the web service
and i really look forward to um
all your feedback why don't we go ahead
and go
go to the questions i am ready to hear
your questions
yeah so there a lot of a lot of
interesting questions
and of course one of them you're already
expecting which is about the long read
and other assemblers
um so are there any plans to have this
work with other assemblers
yeah so this is something that we we
absolutely have thought about and we had
one or two users
asking for it somewhere vocally so
don't despair we're definitely looking
at it i want to make sure that i can
secure
enough developer resources to do that so
i don't have a date to give you
but i really hope we can do that within
the next six months
and a follow-up to that which is
actually an interesting idea
you know we're running the whole thing
but you know what if you had your own
assembly could you potentially
you know we could think about a service
perhaps where you could run rapt
on something without being run pgap on
something without running
the assembly part first uh
do an adaptation of the service that
would run uh pgap only yes
uh this is something that we recently
discussed and
i i don't have an answer yet and how
much work that would be for the
developers but
um we think that would be possible
okay a couple of people ask this which
is a question that i would have too is
you know how big of a how big of an
assembly or how big of an
assembly how big of a set of reads can
you upload to the
service um the web service how big a
file can you upload there
so i think there's an official
officially we
upload up to i want to say the limit is
eight gig
okay uh but i am going to have to double
check with the
with the developers on this and so
the the risk once you have a
very large file is that skeeza
runs out of memory so to give you the
gory details currently
we're running on its cpu machines
um that i believe have something like
30 uh
no they probably have 60 60 gig uh
of memory so it should work
but we have seen with some very very
large data sets such as
i remember 12 gig data set that did
cause
issues with uh skeeza so this is
something that we're keeping
an eye on and if we see that there are a
lot of
failures at this giza step we could
consider
using larger machines okay thank you
let's see we may run out of time if we
don't get to your question
we'll answer it in the document i saw on
the
on your jobs page that you could you
could access your
your runs for up to six weeks that's
that's the case for how long you can
things will stay up there yes that's
correct
uh six weeks after that uh the data will
be deleted from the bucket in which it
lives
and so they'll you'll know they'll know
that it's you because you can you have
to sign into your ncbi account in order
to do that so that's why we can
be sure that we're giving you the right
stuff um yes
that job list is very specific to the
user so what i'm seeing here is only the
one that
i launched i don't see any of the job
that any other person launched and i
only have access to the
the one in the in the past six weeks
another question about um sort of the
accuracy of the p-gap basically
the person says that automated genome
annotation pipelines usually tend to
miss small genes
and small sequence patterns has the
wrapped algorithm and tested for this
uh yeah so we're using the the pgap code
base there's no modification of that
code base in wrap so
i would uh i would point the user to
existing website genomes uh we know
yeah small genes are obviously difficult
and
uh we have very devoted curators who
have built
hmn models specifically for
families of small genes so we can
predict them better
it's not entirely foolproof we have also
in the past year decrease the lower
limit
um the lowest um yeah limit
in size that the coding chin can be
so we are slowly making progress toward
that but
you know obviously some user assumptions
are
are difficult so it is an automated
pipeline
there's no manual creation of the
individual genome so yes some things are
going to slip through
okay just one last thing before we go
because i think we're out of time um
the same person was asking about
transposes and things like that
uh looking for mites miniature inverted
repeat transposable elements
they are does rap detect these kinds of
elements now this person
i think is talking about the pandora
virus and this is not intended to work
with viral sequences yet
not at all no bacteria and narcan
i'd be happy to follow up with any
specific questions about genes
or particular transposes there was an
effort to create hmms for
for for transposable elements so we have
a pretty large collection of hmm for
those so we should be
annotating a lot of them but i can't uh
answer to that specific one
okay we're at time so i think we should
wrap this up and as i said we'll try to
um
we'll try to address questions that are
in the questions pod that we didn't get
to today
thanks everybody for coming and sorry
for the internet problems
all right thanks very much okay i'm
going to end the webinar for everyone